>>> WANT TO GO TO ELLIE HONIG
AND STEPHANIE GRISHAM.
ELLIE, LET ME START WITH YOU.
SOME NEW QUESTIONING FROM THE
"WASHINGTON POST" REPORTING THAT
DOJ INVESTIGATORS HAVE ASKED
GRAND JURY WITNESSES, PEOPLE
LIKE MARC SHORT, ABOUT PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S ACTIONS AS PART OF ITS
CRIMINAL PROBE, ABOUT PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S ACTIONS.
WE KNEW THEY WERE INTERESTED IN
THE PEOPLE AROUND HIM.
THEY'RE SPECIFICALLY SAYING THE
QUESTIONS WERE ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT HIMSELF.
>> WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO MIGHT BE
ABLE TO ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS,
PEOPLE LIKE MARC SHORT AND
POTENTIALLY GREG JACOB.
MERRICK GARLAND, WHEN HE SAYS
NOBODY IS OFF THE TABLE, HE
MEANS IT.
LET'S UNDERSTAND THAT STATEMENT.
HE'S SAYING I'M NOT PLACING
DONALD TRUMP BEYOND OUR REACH,
BUT WHAT'S NOTABLE IS THE DOJ IS
INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE FOR FIRST
TIME.
THAT'S A BIG CHANGE.
>> STEPHANIE, RIGHT THERE ASKING
QUESTIONS, THE REPORTING IS
TALKING ABOUT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
THEY'RE ASKING ABOUT CRIMINAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
MARC SHORT, A FORMER CHIEF OF
STAFF FOR MIKE PENCE, TESTIFIED
IN FRONT OF THE GRAND JURY.
THE GEORGIA CRIMINAL CASE
OBVIOUSLY IS MOVING QUICKLY.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF THINGS MOVING
QUICKLY HERE THAT NOW ARE
TOUCHING TRUMP HIMSELF.
HOW DOES THIS AFFECT HIM RIGHT
NOW?
>> THAT'S A TOUGH QUESTION.
YOU KNOW, HE HAS DODGED SO MANY
DIFFERENT INQUIRIES, LAWSUITS,
ET CETERA.
IF I'M BEING HONEST, I THINK
HE'S SEEING THIS AS A CHALLENGE.
HE'S SEEING IT AS A LOYALTY
TEST.
I WORKED FOR AN ATTORNEY GENERAL
IN ARIZONA.
I KNOW HOW METHODICAL YOU HAVE
TO BE TO BUILD A WINNING CASE.
I BELIEVE THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
DOING.
I BELIEVE SOMETHING WILL COME OF
THIS, BUT RIGHT NOW I THINK HE
THINKS HE'S GOING TO RETAIN HIS
TEFLON DON MONIKER AND NOTHING
WILL HAPPEN.
TODAY HE KEPT HINTING AT HIS
LATEST SPEECH THAT HE WAS GOING
TO RUN.
I THINK THAT'S CONTINUING TO BE
A DISTRACTION AND CONTINUING TO
KEEP HIS BASE RILED UP SO HE
FEELS HE HAS PEOPLE FIGHTING FOR
HIM.
>> FIGHTING FOR HIM AND
DISTRACTED FROM ALL THESE
DEVELOPMENTS THAT ARE COMING OUT
FAST AND FURIOUSLY.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS PART OF
THIS THINGS ARE MOVING MORE
QUICKLY.
THEY PUBLISHED SOME UNDISCLOSED
EMAILS.
EMAILS BETWEEN TRUMP ADVISERS
AND LAWYERS, OUTSIDE LAWYERS
INVOLVED IN THE FAKE ELECTOR
SCHEME.
ONE OF THEM -- THE AIDES THAT
HELPED ORGANIZE THE EFFORT
CALLED THE ELECTORS FAKE AND
FOLLOWS UP IN ANOTHER EMAIL
SAYING, QUOTE, ALTERNATIVE VOTES
IS PROBABLY A BETTER TERM THAN
FAKE, SMILEY FACE.
HOW DAMNING IS THAT?
>> THAT'S A BAD EMAIL FOR THE
PERSON WHO SENT THAT AND THE
PERSON WHO RECEIVED IT.
HERE'S WHY THE FACT ELECTOR
SCHEME IS JUMPING OFF THE PAGE.
WE HAVE A WHOLE SERIES OF
INTERLOCKING PRESSURE CAMPAIGNS
HERE.
THE SUBMISSION OF FALSE SLATES
OF ELECTORS, IT'S TANGIBLE.
THERE'S A TANGIBILITY ABOUT THAT
THAT MAKES IT MORE APPEALING
INVESTIGATIVELY.
>> IN AN EMAIL LIKE THAT YOU
CONTACT SAY IT WAS JUST IN CASE.
IT DOESN'T GET ANY MORE CLEAR
THAN THAT.
>> RIGHT.
>> TRUMP HAD CLAIMED HE
REQUESTED, HE OFFERED NATIONAL
GUARD TROOPS TO BE READY JANUARY
6th.
HIS ACTING DEFENSE SECRETARY,
THE PERSON WHO WOULD HAVE
RECEIVED THAT ORDER SAYS IT'S
NOT TRUE ACCORDING TO NEWLY
RELEASED TESTIMONY HE GAVE TO
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE.
I SHOULD EMPHASIZE UNDER OATH.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> TO BE CRYSTAL CLEAR THERE WAS
NO DIRECT ORDER FROM PRESIDENT
TRUMP TO HAVE 20,000 NATIONAL
GUARD TROOPS RIGHT, CORRECT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THERE WAS NO ORDER FROM THE
PRESIDENT.
>> STEPHANIE, UNDER OATH LOUD
AND CLEAR EXPOSING WHAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT SAID AS UNTRUE.
HOW DAMAGING IS IT?
>> I HATE TO BE A DEBBY DOWNER
HERE.
IT'S VERY DAMAGING IN A REGULAR
SITUATION, BUT HOW MANY PEOPLE
NOW, HOW MANY AIDES WHO WORKED
FOR HIM, HOW MANY REPUBLICANS
SAID THAT'S NOT TRUE.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
HOW MANY THINGS HAVE BEEN PROVEN
NOT TRUE THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
SAID?
I BELIEVE THIS ADDS TO THE CASE
THAT THE PRESIDENT LIES ALL THE
TIME, THE FORMER PRESIDENT I
WANT TO SAY.
I DON'T KNOW HOW DAMAGING IT IS
UNTIL THE DOJ OR THE CASE IN
GEORGIA, SOMETHING HAPPENS TO
HIM.
AT THIS POINT FOR OUR COUNTRY --
THIS IS NO PRESSURE.
AGAIN, I UNDERSTAND HOW HARD IT
IS TO BUILD A WINNING CASE.
UNTIL SOMETHING ACTUALLY HAPPENS
I DON'T KNOW HOW DAMAGING IT IS.
>> WELL, IT'S FAIR AND IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT YOU STATE IT LIKE
YOU SEE IT.
T
THANKS TO BOTH OF YOU.